est-ce que ça se peut d'être allergique
au sexe j'ai un pote qui m'a dit qu'il
éternu quand il est excité allergie au
sexe énorme Mythos et ben ni l'un ni
l'autre il y a effectivement un truc qui
s'appelle la rinite de la lune de miel
c'est un truc qu'on connaît depuis la
fin du 19e siècle on sait pas encore
exactement comment ça marche mais on a
des hypothèse on pense que ça pourrait
être lié à des trucs qu'on a dans le nez
qui s'appell les cornets et qui sont
faits en tissu érectile ça veut dire
qu'ils peuvent se gorger de sang et
gonfler ça vous rappelle un truc non à
la base les cornets ils font ça pour
s'adapter au froid par exemple et il y a
un ORL qui a étudié le phénomène et qui
qui pense que chez certaines personnes
la partie du système nerveux qui
s'occupe de nos autres tissus
érectiles ben en cas d'excitation elle
pourrait aussi envoyer le message
nerveux à nos cornets résultat il gonfle
et ça fait
éternu pardon je passe un très bon
moment avec vous c'est c'est pour ça